OTRAINIAR KHERSON.GOODHI
NDUTORTING
IN MARIUPOL.THOR THED NO POWER,.
AS RUSSIANORCES RRHE INRSE RSR Y
DER RUIANTROL,
THMAYOIS NOWG
RUSSIAN FORCES.TIZENS OUR QHUMA.
SHOWG OSIONS I
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS,IND LIGHUP E
RUSSIAN LITRSLAM AKIV.Y
CIVILIANS WERELE
THNES DED TH
INTENSIR HE EAAS
THITRNOMES OREILS , LARGLETRONO.
FLED THEIR COUNTRY
T OF THE INVASION
JUST SEVEN D
THAY75
WHN IS
, WHAT RUSSIINTENDS A  ANNIHILAT
COUNTRY.
VERY ANGLE OF
THISREY ASCNN AND CORRESND THRO,
IN THEY'N BELGIUM NATODQUARTER O
E HEINOM THE THETEMPE EDICINE.AS
GCOTHEY'RE SAYING TT ARME T
OR OFFSOYI COULD FOLLOW THE
ALD  TOOOVERT D ANNEXEE
SO Y JUST H HE
W
BE
TH THE SITUATIONTIARMAG THATER
THAT I
W, CITWHO WE HAVE
HEARFRNED,Y AT CATASTROPHE IS
UN
IS WIDEAD
TR
SEEDEO OFS NGP TO
THRUN TROOPS RUSSI
KRFLAG
FROMIV THAT WE HRESISTANCE
L ACROSS
US T SOUTHIT NR ODES AN INDICAT
THRUE
THWET ITHE S
TIME, WE'RE ALSO
PRO RUSSRATISTE TRYING THE OTHER
SOY OF
WHICH ISTHE
P, OKHAT, T
ECEA WITST
BN SOUTHEJIM?
BE THE INTENT, TAKE
OVOU.
ALEXAR IYOU  MUCH.  MORNINGHERNE
RUSSIAN FO OF CIVILIAN
RESTM UKIAARR JOINUS NOWD LIKE S
AT THE MAP, IAREPARTICULARLY INH
PARTF Y.AT IS THE PENTAGON VIEW?
>>AR
FL SAYJIM,AU
O  AREA RUSSIANS MAKING
THE BIG
ARE THEY DOIN
THE OF THE THEOROOK ATNEARBYA.E
ESTABLISHED IN THAT .
AND AYSULYLINES, CIL CRN READIL
TOO FAR AYUP PS THAT ARE IN THIF
HE DEPUTY YOD S ACE TH ALSO TCH
VIEWS ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING O.
E DO NOTHOLE
WE DO NOT HA SUPPLY, W NOT HAVES
FOR ONE HALF. CONTINUOU
FOR 26 HOU
26AR
CITY.WEM
ARTILLERY,E,CTICAL ROCKETSMULTI
LAUNCHT SYSTEMY D.
>> 2S OF CTI
SSIAN FORCES.
THISS NOW WHAT S
DIATE CONCERN,
HE TWEAPONS,VIERTIOUS
MBT,NDTHAT THIS  TO STAR
ATH P
NSDARKA LOT OF
LONG
BLE TOOLOUT.JIM?EAH.WITH INT CON
O CREAG CIVILIANS.OSSIBL
HE PENTAGON, K YOU.
E DISTNGVIOSM THE OF THECITY OF
KYIV.
THIS IS  CAMEO CAPTURING
MASSIVE EXPLOSIO.HAVE A WCH.
WE APOAREA.
BRIDGES, FACTORIES
AOTOLLEE GE FROM  BLASTNTN,
OUT.T THN  7
KYIV'S MAICENTRAN.VIDEO WHIC SH
PLATFORM THERE.
CIALS SAY
HILDREN RE BATED
OCCURRMAJOG PIPE ALSO
DAMAGED IN THEACK.
>>> THE TRAIN STN ATTACKCORES WN
INCREANGS JOURNEY R REFUGEES A
DROVES FROUKRAE TY.
THN.THATT
TNCE THE START OF THE INVASIO
FTS COTR
FOR PEPEHR
MOIL SYRIANS TO
NTRY IN , JUST
ONWEPEOPLE
TRYING T TRYING TO GO
TO POL HUNRYHE CZECH
REPUBLIC.
I  ARE THOSERIESO RECEIVE AN
WILLING TO RECEIVE ALL THE
?
ABLE T O, THOUBE
INFLUXKLY.'RT A MILLN OPLE, ANDA
FU COUNTRIES.
ECN IT IS JUST  OF EMERGENCY IN
KNOW HOW MANY MOREHEY WILL BE YI
HERE IS NOT S ANT
WE'RE NOT SEEINGONG MUCHEASIER
OF HRSGETHING BY WERSEY ON.HT
NEARLY AS NG. GOOD
NEWS.
AT STI HERIN
LVIV GE AMIS STIADY STREAM OF P
IL OFOREIGFROM WHAAN TEEN CLEARE
YEERY EYE,  F OF TH
ASKED HIM  THERE.
HE'S ANIANFI, AND HE TTRAIN, HSM
WIE D DAUGHTHAHE WAS LEAVI BO
THEY WILL  SAN'S WHYVENOVE TO UA
Y
T.EL EMO
N'S GONG
IGOING TO  FWIN, BELIEVE.T CHAD
ERHE EN  UAIORY TOESLA
WATOO AND ENTARY, JUST THIS ING.
HE'SNNTAY INAND THEN BDEHERE.
ONE OF